I would love to honor your body of work
um
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Let's Do It
um will you uh take a look at some of
your most pivotal moments in this
birthday round of behind the scenes I'd
love to
[Applause]
I feel like when I personally like fell
in love with you in every sense of the
word was definitely Alias
um
again
I wanted to see women doing what men did
but I you know why I ended up wanting to
do this so badly why Charlie's Angels
you had shown me a new way you had shown
me something that I was like wait that's
possible get me in there I want to do
that that's so fun really yes yes
did you enjoy playing that role every
minute because you were
so amazing oh thank you it was it was
the it was so hard it was so hard 22
Episodes
a year of every single lunch break I had
somebody waiting for me to teach me a
fight to teach me a language to have a
fitting that I mean and and the days
like started at five and they ended at
11 and it obviously there it wasn't hard
there are jobs that are literally hard
it was just so taxing yes and it was
also just heaven to do well you really
like changed my world when you came out
on that show you proved to me that like
we could all do this together
okay catch me if you can really yes
yes
I know I know I know it was crazy Mr
Spielberg
um he was a fan of the first season of
Alias and he just called and said
um I'm doing this movie and I've added
in a little scene that we want you to do
and I got to do that scene and it was
just like I was floating the whole day
what's working with Leonardo DiCaprio
like
I mean I had I I had one day of it but
one day is enough
but he's just such a good actor yeah you
know he just really is a he just is
really good at his job yeah yeah God I
know my fantasies are correct cool okay
okay okay
this movie means so much to me and my
daughters it meant so much to me when it
came out and it means oh I know
hey
[Music]
can you stand it
I know Joy it was joy that was joy that
was just Joy did you did you know when
you were making it that it was going to
be a classic nope no idea and I just had
dinner with Judy Greer who plays my
friend of me yeah I know of course and I
just talked about me yes oh no I know
every line from the movie hilarious
been kissed
yeah yeah
[Applause]
so we have Alias and Charlie's we have
never been kissed in 13. going on 30.
see these are the reasons why I follow
you like you know
um but yes I did not I just knew that I
mean it we've talked about it the three
of us how it kind of grows instead of I
mean they because I think the kids who
were 13 when it came out are now 30. and
God bless him if they're already flirty
and thriving
yes okay so we know that you are the
artistic Ambassador for save the
children and uh as another birthday gift
we got together with our friends at Spin
Master and they're actually donating 25
000 uh to their local save the children
organization
thank you so much thank you
and however
[Applause]
um
they also want to donate these actual
play kits and there are going to be 500
of them and they're all filled with toys
such as Rubik's cubes and
etch-a-sketches and they want to help
bring the joy to the children all around
the globe for a total donation of over
two hundred thousand dollars in honor of
you for save the children
it's the biggest giveaway we've ever
done
oh wow
your kids don't have toys thank you
literally kids don't have toys they
don't have books and they don't have
toys and you're just making that happen
thank you so much it's all in honor of
you
these are your examples so we're just
following in your footsteps including
Once Upon A Farm which you know I love
and we got to do this show together
before and I was so excited I eat that
you feed me on airplanes
I've been so kind you're so supportive
but I love that company and I love that
you show that you know you can be an
entrepreneur you can do something that
is authentic to you and we just love the
mission of Once Upon a farm and to keep
the birthday fun going they're going to
give everyone in the audience a hundred
dollar gift card
um to get some Farm Fresh snacks
nobody
to me it's this all national Jennifer
Garner and everything that you do and by
the way okay oh hold on what you
actually came here to talk about a
project I know I'm so freaked out about
what you're gonna do to me next
foreign
[Music]